hola hola bienvenidos lo que voy a hacer
es usar esta aplicación la que vemos
aquí en pantalla para gráficas y
explorar las funciones trigonométricas o
las gráficas de estas funciones y bueno
para empezar esta aplicación la estoy
usando de la página heck al punto net es
que sea el punto net no es mía pero
quiero dar crédito por usarla así que
bueno espero no se molesten así que
bueno iniciamos graficando a unas
funciones iniciamos con la función seno
qué te parece la función seno lo escribo
aquí arriba y bueno mira qué hermoso
sale ahí está guau genial ok
aquí vamos a interpretar todo esto está
oscilando está oscilando bueno mejor
vayamos punto por punto d es la manera
más sencilla de hacerlo cuando x es
igual a 0 cuál es el valor de la función
veamos cuál es cuando x igual a 0
lo dice aquí abajo en lo gris aquí lo
puedes ver aquí abajo en lo gris
cuando x es igual a 0 que también es
igual a 0 cierto ahí está y ahora si
recuerdas cuando definimos lo que es el
círculo unitario cuando dimos la
definición eso fue lo que obtuvimos que
el seno de 0 radiales es justamente 0 y
ahora mientras nos movemos sobre la
curva aquí aquí nos vamos moviendo y
justo en este punto cuando llegamos a
este punto si observamos la parte gris
en la parte baja de la pantalla dice que
x es igual a 1.57 pero que es eso 1.57
si estás familiarizado con este número
es comúnmente conocido como la mitad de
que el número famoso exacto es la mitad
de pi
entonces hay ese punto es pi medios y si
quieres convertir y medios a grados
estamos hablando de 90 grados por lo
tanto cuando estamos en el ángulo pi
sobre dos radiales la función seno es
igual a uno y es justo lo que vimos en
el círculo unitario en otros vídeos
sobre el círculo unitario y la función
seno ahí estamos en el punto 10 del
círculo unitario espero que esté
confundiendo t ahora
pero seguiremos seguimos con esto una
cosa que yo quiero introducir en este
vídeo es el concepto de periodo o la
frecuencia de la función seno y supongo
que es muy obvio para ti que la función
la función se repite cierto espero lo
sea porque va de cero luego va a 1 y
después otra vez a 0 después a menos 1 y
así regresa a cero entonces se repite
como tú puedes ver por lo tanto el
periodo de esta función periódica es
esta distancia la distancia de aquí a
este punto de este punto a este punto
que es justamente 2 y radiant es cierto
de aquí hasta acá es 2 bryant es y eso
tiene sentido claro que lo tienes claro
que sí porque dos pies radiales es una
revolución completa sobre el círculo
unitario luego se vuelve a repetir y en
la otra dirección así que vas de dos
pilares hacia atrás luego se vuelve a
repetir y así sucesivamente entonces
bueno es muy interesante no creerá yo
estoy fascinada ahora entre cuales los
números oscila oscila entre el uno
positivo y uno negativo y tiene total
sentido porque el círculo unitario
tiene radio uno entonces no puede
rebasar del uno y ahora bueno es la
razón por la cual la función se no
oscila entre esos dos puntos dejaré aquí
por un momento la función seno de xy
vemos ahora la función coseno de x y ahí
está interesante porque porque se ve
casi idéntica solo que trasladada se
mira trasladada a la izquierda pi sobre
dos radiales y ese es en efecto el caso
así que pensemos en por qué pasa esto
primero que todo pensemos en porque
sabemos que sabemos que el seno de cero
es cero y eso lo vimos en el inicio del
vídeo si lo recuerda si no puedes
regresarlo pero si observas la función
verde el coste no de cero radiales es 1
si lo puedes ver es 1 entonces veamos
por qué no puedo atrás no puedo trazar
la función coseno pero no pasa nada no
me deja ahora bueno simplemente
hagámoslo así el coste no de cero es 1 y
eso porque tiene sentido
jose no es la coordenada x del círculo
unitario y cuando tú tienes 0 radiales o
0 grados estás ubicándose en el punto 10
del círculo unitario entonces uno
corresponde al coche no es la coordenada
x y 0 es el valor y corresponde al seno
ahora si para ti esto es confuso regresa
al vídeo donde yo uso el círculo
unitario para resolver los valores de
las funciones trigonométricas y ahora
nota que esto tiene un periodo similar a
la función seno porque mira aquí está
inicia en 1 y después después baja a 1
negativo baja 1 negativo luego regresa a
uno positivo y puedes ver que toma dos
pi radiales para completar un ciclo
nuevamente justo como la función seno
está oscilando entre 1 y 1 negativo y
bueno esto es porque en el ciclo
unitario no puedes exceder del radio 1
cierto tiene radio 1 y no puedes exceder
de ese y ahora para llegar al final de
la presentación queda ver la función
tangente asíque tangente de xy igual ahí
está está hermoso esto ahora la línea
morada es la función tangente y por qué
hace esta locura está como medio
psicodélico no porque se mira así
si recuerdas la función tangente es
igual y es sobre x en el círculo en el
perímetro del ciclo unitario y como la i
es igual al seno y el coste no es la x
también es equivalente a 0 sobre coseno
y así aquí tangente de 0 siempre y
cuando el seno sea cero y eso tiene
sentido porque tangente es igual a seno
sobre cose no tiene sentido que cuando
seno es igual a cero tangente es igual a
cero pero después mientras la función
seno se hace mayor la función coseno se
hace menor el numerador en la función
tangente se hace mayor porque el
numerador es c no obtenemos valores más
y más y más altos cada vez hasta llegar
al punto en el que el denominador el
denominador de la función tangente
espero no confundirse con tantas líneas
creo que es el vídeo más confuso que he
hecho hasta el momento
no creo que hecho peor esa no es cierto
pero aquí tenemos las funciones en un
coseno y tangente sus gráficas ahora el
denominador va de 0 90 en gente de
tangencia dispara se dispara y se
aproxima infinito si observas el círculo
unitario tendrá más sentido todo esto y
cabe mencionar que
la función tangente tiene un periodo de
pi en lugar de dos y de hecho sería muy
bueno que lo investigaran ahora ya con
todo esto voy a reiniciar esto voy a
dibujar la función se no se no ahora
dibujará la función se no digamos seno
de 2x seno de 2x me funciona muy bien
entonces seno de 2x y no pese está muy
mal esa no es la función que estoy
buscando a cómo le hago aquí tal vez con
paréntesis a ver ahí está ahí está
entonces pero pero lo voy a reiniciar y
primero voy a dibujar la función seno de
x para comparar seno de x y después seno
de 2x perfecto y bueno aunque es lo
primero que notas en la diferencia entre
estas dos funciones la caf es la de seno
de xy la verdad es la de seno de 2x
ambas tienen como tú puedes notar ambas
oscilan entre los mismos valores y un
dato un dato sólo para que lo sepas la
altura de la oscilación es llamada la
amplitud de esta función periódica en
ambos casos la amplitud es 1 porque está
oscilando desde 1 a menos 1 por lo tanto
la amplitud es 1 pero su periodo es
diferente porque seno de x tomados
irradian es para completar un ciclo
mientras mientras que seno de 12 x toma
solo pi radiales para completar un ciclo
entonces entonces no está siendo lo
completa el doble de rápido y de hecho
piensen por qué sucede eso porque la
función seno de 2x tiene la mitad de
período que la función seno de x
tal vez puedas adivinar qué sucede si yo
pongo si yo pongo seno de 3x seno de 3x
o tal vez sí o no mejor seno de 4x
deberá tener la mitad del periodo que la
función seno de 2x y así es decir ahí lo
puedes ver aunque la gráfica tal vez
esté un poco confusa entonces creo que
ya entiende es que que hace el
coeficiente frente a la x cuando tienes
un coeficiente mayor lo que hace es
ponerle más velocidad a los ciclos así
que exploremos un poco más esto
iniciamos con seno de x otra vez y ahora
en lugar de hacer el coeficiente mayor
hagamos el coeficiente menor hagamos 2.5
equis y bueno mira esto un de repente
toma cuatro operaciones para completar
un ciclo y quiero que piensen por qué es
así por qué sucede esto ahora estamos
haciendo lento un poco más lento como
recorre todo el ciclo en cada ángulo así
que ya con todo esto que sucede con la
amplitud
veamos jugamos un poco con la amplitud
tenemos seno de equis qué crees que
suceda si yo pongo
si yo pongo dos por el seno de x aquí
aquí el periodo es el mismo sigue siendo
2 espn
pero debes notar que oscila entre dos y
menos dos lo puedes ver entre dos y
menos dos en lugar de oscilar entre uno
y menos uno por lo tanto cualquiera sea
el coeficiente frente a la función en
este caso estamos hablando de la función
seno
ese coeficiente afecta a su amplitud y
similarmente podemos mirar cómo se ve en
el caso de punto 5 seno de qué te parece
2x pondré 2x punto 50 de 2x ahí está muy
interesante entonces ahora sólo llega a
punto 5 y baja a menos punto 5 entonces
tenemos que su amplitud es de punto 5 y
también oscilan el doble de rápido que
la función seno porque era 2 seno de 2x
y bueno aquí aquí le dejo por el momento
tengo tengo el presentimiento de haberse
confundido más entonces
haré otro vídeo haré otro vídeo donde no
no usar esta gráfica sino voy a
escribirlo todo entonces hasta pronto
nos vemos nos vemos después bye